et voilà
alors
et ben tout est bon comme la semaine
dernière en fait oui
ça prévient pas
il faut le faire régulièrement voilà
c'est irrégulier tout de même hein
c'est pas votre cœur le problème
une vie entière sous paroxétine non
commençons par 10 mg ça vous va 10 mg
ça sert à rien 20 comme d'hab c'est
câbles à la limite et puis je montrais
comme ça de 10 à 20 mais
cette chimie dans mon corps tout fournit
compte
mettez-moi du xanax aussi en cas de
grosse crise quand même quoi que non
c'est pas
pas qu'est-ce qu'on dit ça c'est le
grand dilemme mettez-moi les deux puis
je ferai ma tambouille voilà
renouvelable évidemment non substituable
en revanche ou générique d'ailleurs
c'est que c'est comme vous voulez c'est
vous le médecin
[Rires]
à toi mon amour
ça va
[Musique]
mille balles ça isole [ __ ] je voulais
les rendre merci Lucie bon et ça dit
quoi alors rien du tout hein
comme d'habitude là ils veulent pas de
mettre quand ils ont tort
hello Lucie ça va
oui c'est top en face c'est tout je suis
la structure
j'ai rien à structurer là tu vois mais
oui c'est ça comme d'habitude non non là
vraiment je te jure là
c'est pour ça je partir maintenant je
vais faire que me répéter quoi qu'est-ce
que tu veux qu'on fasse les garçons et
les filles c'est pas pareil oh là là je
me sens moche alors je bois de la vodka
je vais me répéter là tu vois c'est bon
même c'est comme ça tu veux parler de
quoi tu parles de toi c'est ça les
artistes
faut que je me soigne déjà parce que je
fais pas mal de crises d'angoisse à
nouveau là je sais pas ce que tu joues
pas quand tu joues pas du tout c'est
biologique j'en prends des cachetons et
déjà j'irai mieux c'est de la merde tes
antidépresseurs ça marche pas tu vois
bien c'est comme le wi-fi bon alors on
fait quoi on reste là comme des cons je
sais pas on attend que les plus grand
marche on ouvre des cachetons non c'est
juste que là deux secondes voilà là j'ai
pas de j'ai pas de fulgurance j'ai eu
que des van de merde limite ou des
petites observations du quotidien mais
pas de quoi écrire un spectacle quoi je
te le dis quoi vas-y non c'est nul
[Musique]
si oui l'autre jour c'est nul mais
l'autre jour j'étais dans une boutique
j'ai acheté un truc et je paye en carte
bleue et tu sais quand tu payes en carte
bleue tu fais ton code et le terminal il
dit quoi bon tu vois et je me dis c'est
nul ça sert à rien on s'en fout quoi de
bon pas la peine de me féliciter je sais
que il est bon c'est le mien j'ai pas
tapé au hasard c'est ridicule c'est
comme si à chaque fois que j'arrive chez
moi il y a quelqu'un qui me dit ah bravo
c'est bien là
je sais pas moi j'aime bien qu'ils
écrivent que bon parce que comme ça je
sais que je me suis pas trompé tu vois
[Rires]
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
avec plaisir
je vous laisse remplir la fiche
d'information
merci
excusez-nous c'est parce qu'on est
débutante on n'a jamais fait donc un peu
stressé vous inquiétez pas ici on ne se
juge pas
ine
[Musique]
bonjour à tous
bienvenue installez-vous tranquillement
les jambes croisées
faites les derniers ajustements pour
votre tenue votre position
merci c'est gentil le sommet du crâne
vers le haut les mains sont posées sur
les genoux aux yeux sont fermés en
douceur la seule à main en arrière une
main sur le genou crème mouvement de
rotation regardez loin derrière vous
essayez de vous grandir davantage
chercher à manger davantage votre bus
repassez par le Centre et même chose de
l'autre côté
créez vraiment cette hauteur tirer le
sommet du crâne en grandissez vous
repassez tranquillement dans le centre
et transférer le poids du corps sur les
genoux et sur les mains le poignet à la
plomb des épaules les genoux séparés
largeurs du bassin exagéré la levée des
fesses tirer le regard vers le haut et
inspirer fort
sur l'expiration arrondissez le dos et
bomber revenez en position neutre
orteil dans le sol et relevez les fesses
vers le plafond pour venir downddock
dans le chien tête en bas de cette
position et levez votre jambe droite
vers le point le plus haut trouvez le
point culminant ni sans chercher
vraiment à avoir le pied droit qui
flirte avec le plafond rester fermement
votre pied gauche dans le sol jambe
gauche tendu
même chose de l'autre côté
pied séparée largeur de votre bassin
Florence largeur du bassin
[Musique]
voilà
ensemble placez votre pied droit à
l'intérieur de votre cuisse gauche
compresser le talon à l'intérieur de
votre adducteur interne de votre cuisse
votre posture est ancrée concentration
est à toute épreuve vous êtes totalement
inébranlable
sentez-vous léger alignés cherchez
vraiment à sentir cette légèreté cet
ancrage dans votre corps respirez très
profondément attraper derrière vos
genoux et rouler doucement pour venir
avec moi dans la posture de la charrue
les genoux fléchis les pierres relâchent
en arrière tu vois une posture dans
laquelle vous êtes confortable une
respiration profonde
ah non mais moi je suis pas sûr
d'accrocher oh non attends j'ai pris
deux abonnements
merci merci à quelle heure ce soir alors
il faudrait être à 19h si tu veux je
passe te prendre non non je prends un
taxi
super merci de rien et donc après dîner
présentation vers 20h30 à tranquillement
et ensuite donc enchères
s'il vous plaît
ton frère alors il a kiffé les
chaussures ben oui ici oui oui il adore
Michel ah bah il en est fou hein
ça te dérange pas si je te tutoie
tu veux prendre un café
je suis pas très fan de la cuisine
asiatique en fait impossible je te jure
je dis ça parce que tu t'es jamais fait
un bon chinois
peut-être
et dis-moi elle est à toi la Fiat 500 la
petite bleue
je trouve ça tellement plus chic
a du charme quoi
ça a vécu et sinon tu fais quoi en ce
moment là tu t'écris un spectacle ben
j'essaye en fait mais j'ai pas beaucoup
de respiration là je cherche enfin je
suis pas j'ai l'impression que j'ai
besoin de vivre des nouvelles choses tu
vois des expériences un peu
nouvelles
je sais que dans ce cas là moi je peux
t'aider
parce qu'à la boutique je dois passer
des gens tous les jours mais j'ai des
anecdotes
de rire
mais en tout cas faut vite que tu
rentres sur scène
parce que ma mère elle t'a tort mais un
truc de malade elle est fan de toi
elle me parle de toi
[Rires]
tu fais un truc ce soir parce que
j'organise un petit ticket à la maison
j'ai le cancer je peux pas j'ai le j'ai
une soirée contre le cancer pardon
désolé oui bah non c'est plus important
mais peut-être une autre fois non
[Musique]
papa bonjour bonjour ça va attention à
vous
vous êtes incognito moi je vous ai
reconnu non non c'est je sors du sport
c'est tout
alors vous inquiétez pas parce que
aujourd'hui je ne prends pas de photos
merci mais j'ai imprimé celle de la
dernière fois pour que vous la signer
j'ai pas de style
alors
un H et deux p
en bas vous mettez pas gros bisous
merci beaucoup bisous
par contre ça c'est pas moi
qu'est-ce que vous faites là
si quand on frappe pas la porte et qu'il
y a pas effraction la magie un peu
je suis pas angoissé là je vais très
bien
[Rires]
c'est de penser à moi mon petit bonhomme
ça me fera des vacances je pense pas
vous
puis toute façon je suis équipé ah moi
je peux me débarrasser de vous comme ça
je tremble
un
elle te va comme un gant écoute c'est
hyper chic c'est hyper beau
ah ouais c'est hyper beau c'est hyper
beau mais juste c'est pas trop le c'est
pas trop le style de la soirée quoi tu
sais c'est une soirée caritative et là
je trouve c'est quand même très très
décolleté très court tu vois si non
c'est fou parce que quand je dis que
j'aime pas le la bouffe chinoise c'est
tout le monde essaye de me faire changer
d'avis tu vois genre c'est parce que tu
t'es jamais fait tu t'es jamais fait un
bon chinois mais c'est fou de dire ça je
veux dire tu dis pas un pote gay ah ben
ça c'est parce que tu t'es jamais fait
une bonne meuf en attendant
voilà tu vois non mais là d'accord ah
bah voilà tu vois je sais moi j'aime
mieux l'autre mais celle-là est plus
dans le c'est beau aussi ouais tu vois
elle est plus dans le ton voilà c'est ça
mon chou messieurs dames prenez place on
est sobre on est chic on n'est pas voilà
tu vois c'est dans le elle me fait un
peu grosse par contre non je trouve
pas du tout non non ça va avec les
talons tout ça non
notre dernière innovation pour lutter
contre la forme de certains cancers et
la biopsie liquide cette technique de
plus en plus utilisée dans le diagnostic
des cancers est très prometteuse en
effet la biopsie liquide permet une
analyse dynamique rapide en temps réel
de l'évolution de la tumeur des patients
et ce pratiquer de manière non invasive
et à moindre coût bien évidemment vous
voyez c'est très important dans la lutte
contre le cancer merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup docteur merci Docteur
merci infiniment
et bien il est temps maintenant
d'écouter les témoignages de deux
héroïnes qui ont eu la générosité de
venir nous parler de leur combat face à
la maladie on applaudit tout d'abord
Laurine s'il vous plaît
bonsoir merci beaucoup merci c'est
beaucoup d'émotions d'être devant vous
ce soir
ça va c'est bien super merci
la chimiothérapie j'ai vu mon corps
dépérir c'était bien ton café
et je sais que mon combat est encore
long pour la guérison et incertain mais
s'il y a bien une chose dont je suis sûr
aujourd'hui c'est que je veux plus me
cacher
[Applaudissements]
bravo merci merci beaucoup quelle
témoignage
votre prochain spectacle c'est quand
dans trois mois à peu près l'avion
Barbie vous l'avez vu évidemment
drôle ah non mais je le regardais tout
le temps pendant ma chimio ça me fait
plaisir vraiment merci
vous devez avoir une vie tellement
géniale
non mais ça doit être fou d'avoir du
succès comme ça de l'argent de l'humour
et puis alors la célébrité c'est dingue
dingue oui enfin bon c'est pas non plus
l'essentiel de la vie bah nous on ce qui
compte c'est d'avoir la santé je pense
[Musique]
enfin la santé le bien-être quoi général
l'épanouissement personnel curiosité le
goût des autres voilà voilà
il y a des moments ça peut être très
très dur à vivre ah oui très dur comme
la chimio
champagne alors sachez mesdames que vous
êtes tout invité au prochain spectacle
de Florence vous venez à combien vous
voulez
avoir le champagne
je vous laisserai mon petit numéro de
téléphone et puis vous n'hésitez pas
on passe aux enchères tu vois
ouais on y va parce qu'après on va se
coucher tard
mess vraiment fini les assiettes et
dégager voilà c'est bon merci on va y
aller on se
[Musique]
je suis là
voilà merci super un deux un deux
entendez super messieurs dames je crois
qu'il est temps de lancer les fameuses
enchères on est là pour ça et nous
allons démarrer tout de suite par le
premier lot qui se trouve être une une
montre voilà de marque Rolex
connais pas jamais entendu parler voilà
qui est magnifique elle a mise a pris
les deux
5500 euros seulement c'est grotes alors
qui va pour 5500 génial 5500 monsieur
6000 peut-être merci monsieur vous êtes
bien raison 6005 peut-être 6500 adjugé
vendu c'est à vous
7000 non c'est trop franchement c'est
trop 65 c'est parfait ça se trouve elle
est pas waterproof donc ça sert à rien
de dépenser des sommes oh [ __ ] alors
on liquide on liquide 16000 euros pour
qui très bien Madame adjugé vendu on
enchaîne ah oui mais non mais oui mais
il faut être réactive madame on n'est
pas aux prises unique ah oui mais c'est
comme ça les enchères là ça enchaîne
allez tout doit disparaître 600 euros
madame il est à vous les petits
bonhommes
petit Bouddha les petits boudins ah
voilà venez chercher votre présence de
pêche non poussez-vous mettre regardez
ça va plus vite on va pas s'embêter avec
les papiers vous ferez ça tout à l'heure
non non mais venez pas chercher les prix
tous les uns après les autres parce
qu'on va faire trop du temps mais restez
à la fin de la soirée allez hop on va
laisser creuser
on va passer enfin au dernier lot de
cette vente aux enchères il s'agit je
crois d'un grand cru millésimé
Saint-Émilion je crois mais c'est une
très très belle bouteille une très belle
bouteille que
je vais mettre du jet voilà ça me fait
plaisir j'adore le vin voilà le prix de
réserve étant de 25000 €
belle contribution à la recherche que je
suis en train de faire
mais tu la gardes bien moi je connais un
collectionneur
bon ça va je suis comment
allez respire
[Musique]
on se voit
je suis trop contente de vous avoir dans
ma voiture merci beaucoup avez-vous fait
trop marrer je vous jure ah vous êtes la
meilleure c'est gentil ça merci beaucoup
et ma sœur c'est pire que moi et vous
adore ah bon ah ouais ouais quand je
vais lui dire attendez ça vous dérange
pas on l'appelle là vraiment je suis un
peu labour en fait je suis désolé hein
tu t'es videras jamais que j'ai dans ma
voiture allez allez prendre comique de
France
bonjour bonjour ben voilà je suis dans
la voiture de votre sœur donc je vous
fais un bisou je vous la repasse
voilà c'est Florence Foresti merci c'est
bon alors de dingue c'est où faut y
aller madame
vas-y je raccroche parce qu'elle a l'air
un peu pressée allez en route incroyable
alors là et puis trop belle en plus
merci c'est gentil
qu'est-ce qui t'arrive fils de [ __ ] va
non il y a pas de fils de [ __ ] tout va
bien quoi qu'est-ce qu'il y a il est où
le problème là on y va voilà il va nous
insulter après
il va nous taper
[Applaudissements]
tu veux que je descende
personne on n'a pas le temps
j'ai
[Musique]
pleuré
je suis désolé
voilà joyeux anniversaire maman
[Applaudissements]
je vous ressemble
une photo voilà voilà
il faut que je te présente ma copine
Alizée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]